los obispos se reúnen en Lourdes al
suroeste de Francia para hacer frente a
un nuevo escándalo de acoso sexual en el
centro de la última revelación el
cardenal Jean Pierre uno de los más
altos prelados de la Iglesia Católica
francesa de admitió sus abusos en una
declaración escrita el lunes
hace 35 años cuando era sacerdote me
comporté de forma reprobable con una
niña de 14 años mi comportamiento causó
inevitablemente consecuencias graves y
duraderas en esta persona
la confesión del cardenal se produce
apenas un mes después de otro caso de
abuso sexuales que sacudió a la iglesia
católica el exobispo del critea Michelle
Santiago se retiró el año pasado tras
ser acusado de hacer desnudar a chicos
jóvenes por cada pecado confesado una
investigación independiente realizada en
2021 estimó más de 200.000 víctimas de
abusos por parte del clero en Francia
desde los años 50
el hecho de la celebración de esta rueda
de prensa sobre la revelación relativa
al cardenal ricard todo está
evidentemente relacionado hay una mayor
concienciación en la iglesia
católicas franceses han sido acusados de
violencia sexual o de no denunciar en
los casos de abuso y se enfrentan a un
juicio o a un tribunal eclesiástico los
obispos deben anunciar el martes las
medidas disciplinarias que pondrán en
marcha para acabar con la impunidad en
la iglesia